de laurent bouvet projet idéologique
planty policier il ya une au moment où
la gauche le parti socialiste avec les
verts essentiellement et quelques autres
partis plus petits ont gagné la mairie
de paris en 2001 avec bertrand delanoë
puis ensuite donc jusqu'à maintenant
avec anne hidalgo
les verts sont devenus comme le parti
communiste l'été avant la pointe avancée
du combat progressiste ses terres que
les socialistes et ça déteint d'ailleurs
sur le parti socialiste qui explique en
grande partie aussi les problèmes du
parti ceci d'ailleurs qu'avant les
socialistes il est bon on est
révolutionnaire on est on est pour le
socialisme bon enfin il ya les
communistes et les vrais quand même bon
mais on nous on veut pas faire la
révolution mais on est plus calme et
enfin bon on partage les vues comme un
fin du communisme mur de berlin
arrive la question écologique qui
devient pour la gauche le grand progrès
du 21e siècle et dans cette question
écologique effectivement je suis tout à
fait d'accord cette idéologique la
voiture et le la pièce à abattre de la
vieille société industrielle du thon
doit sortir une voiture privée mais oui
mais nous étions privés la provision non
parce que le problème de la pollution
il ya eu un rapport il ya deux trois
jours d'airparif qe1 airparif c'est un
organisme indépendant
mais c'est un organisme qui est pas
éloigné de la mairie de paris
mon bold pas à l'organisme de par
exemple du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france qui serait contre la
mairie de paris tend ses conclusions sur
les berges explique que sur les voies
sur berge
la pollution a diminué évidemment il y
avait deux voitures mais qu'elle s'est
reportée et quand on explique ça moi
j'ai ce débat très souvent avec des gens
qui sont pour les mesures anti voiture
je leur dis mais le report de la
pollution montre que c'est pas un
problème de pollution c'est ce que
disait alexis brisé par exemple il n'ya
pas de covoiturage sur les voies sur
berge
il n'y a pas de réserve on réserve pas
les voies sur berge au covoiturage pour
avec avec des lignes comme ça se fait
dans tous les pays du monde
si vous êtes plus de 2 dans la voiture
vous avez le droit d'utiliser les voies
sur berge si vous n'êtes pas + 2 vous
êtes sanctionné
donc ça veut dire effectivement cette
idéologie que c'est la voiture privée
qui est le problème
et cette question est une question
éminemment politique pourquoi parce que
considéré que tous les parisiens qui ont
une voiture cette minorité de 40%
sondé des entre guillemets pardonnez moi
moi j'appelle ça des nazes immobiliste
c'est à dire des gens qui sont des
[ __ ] parce qu'ils ont une voiture
parce qu'ils ont besoin de leur voiture
parce que non je rigole mais c'est un
terme caricatural mais cette idée c'est
que ces gens sont doivent être
effectivement contrées que politiquement
et en or ces gens là et on pourrait
faire le test très facilement et moi je
le fais par là de mon exemple on fait
aussi du vélo on prend aussi des
transports en commun on a des enfants on
n'a pas envie de les voir mourir de
pollution nos enfants enfin je veux dire
c'est cette idée que de toute façon
parce qu'on est une voiture on est
quelqu'un de totalement irresponsable
qui veut tuer ses enfants février sais
j'exagère je caricature c'est un
problème secondes